that is the hilarious Janelle James from
the Emmy award-winning show all the rage
most successful show on television thank
you everybody Abbott Elementary
okay so going into the break I asked you
is it true that Chris Rock cold called
you
and how did that happen
uh it was yeah around this time I think
it was a day after Christmas about five
years ago and I had been doing stand-up
for about five years at that time and I
had an unknown number pop up on my phone
and I'll who answers that and I answered
it for for uh whatever reason and it was
and I said hello and he said Janelle
James Christopher Rock like that and I
was like get the get the hell
and you know I'm a comedian can he
announces himself as Christopher but I'm
glad he did because I'm a comedian we're
all jerks it could have been somebody
pranking me and if he had said Chris
Rock I would have hung up I'd have been
like whoever this is leave me alone but
Christopher rock is I'm like oh this is
Chris Rock like interesting but he was
my first big uh tour like he took me on
tour with him and that yeah yeah
and that like introduced me to like such
a you know a way broader fan base than I
had at the time which were just like
white dudes in the Midwest
um okay so you play like you know the
bad boss on the show you've got tons of
attitude I love your character so much
thank you did you base your character on
anyone like did you know who she was I
read it and I was like oh this lady is
crazy and uh I remember when we were
shooting I said I'm gonna be nuts with
her and do that and be zany and be
hilarious because she does a lot of
awful things so she has to be compelling
in a lot of ways she has to be Charming
she has to be you know on and and and
hilarious so uh it's a amazing I guess
what actors call a dream role is so fun
and it's not easy to do it's not pull it
off so brilliantly true people think
comedy is easy it's not exactly
okay I love this story so much about you
are working at pretzel time I was that
was my first job youngest manager in
pretzel Town history by the way but
anyway
[Applause]
Chris Rock who pretzels oh but um no
it's I I it uh it was a great job for me
because I had a lot of responsibilities
but then I quit it for the most benign
reasons which you would do still I quit
jobs for any reason uh and the reason
for that place we had a lovely almost
this color Champagne uh beige Ensemble
and then they changed it to bright neon
pink and I was like people will see me I
don't know
I'm out of here
out of here see I love that about you
um what were you like as a student oh I
was very studious I'm I'm a nerd I'm
still a nerd and I I my mom we you know
I grew up poor so like most people and
uh my mom was really good at making
small things seem like such a big uh
gift so going to the library was like
going to Disneyland for us like and if
you messed up or misbehave it's like
you're not gonna get books this week and
I would ball like I was a real big
reader I still am and taking education
very seriously is what made me who I am
now I'm so in love with you I really am
all right
um would you play my favorite game with
me red flag green flag yellow flag all
right all right here we go
thank you
all right we're gonna put 60 seconds on
the clock all right here we go oh boy
you're at the movies and after every
single preview your date leans in and
says that one looks good
okay perfect I'm like okay your date
keeps calling you Milady oh my God
the guy you've been seeing shows up at
your door unannounced what do you got
with them
anything you want
you're at a party and your date pulls an
Irish accent they just disappear
yeah I agree I agree
um what if he said we're going to both
pull an Irish exit together I love that
all right perfect your date shoes with
his mouth open
he says he'll pick you up at 8pm but he
arrives at 7 30.
yeah that is like presumptuous yeah for
me I'm not ready
at the time I'm not gonna be ready at
eight I'm always late but God do I hate
early people all right your date signed
you up for um a date to surprise you and
it's skydiving
I love you
get out of here
Janelle I think you are the coolest
I'm in elementary Wednesdays at 9pm on
ABC and streaming on Hulu
[Music]